I didn't know that this was a camp area.
Oh,
you see all the campers?
Yeah.
Right out in front of you of the place.
They're everywhere.
Well,
they finally side streets where the cops won't kick them out.
Yeah.
And semi homeless people.
They're not homeless.
They just have mobile homes.
You know what it is that the homeless people here,
it's so peaceful there like,
uh,
like the caravan,
you know,
they just,
they don't bump change.
They don't do anything.
They just kind of walk around.
I'm,
I'm sitting in front of your building here.
It was like a fashion show for the homeless.
One guy comes by with a buffalo bills jacket and the other guys then,
you know,
and they just quietly talking to themselves
and you know what's freaking me out?
I've only been here 12 hours,
but
everybody is either really soft spoken are,
I'm losing my fucking hearing because like even at though I'm renting the car
and the woman says,
[inaudible] a Honda,
do you want us?
I said,
what?
What did you want a sign that said what?
You know,
in Boston it'd be like,
what do you want for a cat?
You want to be upgraded.
You know,
it's like the noise pollution.
Well,
it's louder there and colder and people are angrier.
It's a different place out here.
It's just,
even the homeless people,
they don't have it so rough.
If you're going to be a homeless person,
this is the place to go.
People are very open minded.
It's relaxed,
it's warm.
I mean the coldest it gets is like 40.
That's as cold as it ever gets.
Yeah.
But you know,
if you're giving advice to homeless people,
it's like,
like I was,
I was sitting in Westwood and a Starbucks,
right.
And it's,
the guy was just sitting there,
you know,
and all these people are having their lattes and shit and he's just,
okay.
You know,
one of those crazy laughs,
everybody's just gone along with their conversation,
you know,
the,
uh,
I don't know what to say about the,
about the homeless thing.
Have you ever been in downtown?
Do you ever seen my Kiddo?
I myself was homeless when I was like 16.
I was a hippie father passed away when I was 15.
And,
okay.
It was a different time,
you know?
No,
I haven't been down.
So you were homeless for like how long?
I was a hippy and it's different than being homeless,
but a couple of years.
Really.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
you know,
the worst moment I was lying,
I was downstairs in this guy's house and I overheard his girlfriends saying no.
He was saying it was girlfriend.
I don't know.
I keep asking the guy to leave,
but you know,
I was,
uh,
you know,
I was,
here's what happened.
I Made Joe,
I Read Jack Kerouac on the road.
Okay.
So I wanted to beat Jack Carol whack and I wanted to be a writer.
So I did everything that Carol Act did,
except right.
You know,
I was living in YMCAs and drinking the wine and the whole thing,
but it was a whole different country then.
Why didn't you start writing wasn't one of those things like eventually you'll
start writing or writing.
I going to be a writer.
I didn't want to fucking right.
You know what I mean?
Right.
Like you writing the artist,
you don't want to paint.
Right?
Writing's the hardest job in the world.
I don't know how people do it.